the last time we did a trailer reaction
to the boys
did you see the boys no you've
recommended you son of a [ __ ]
i i'm sorry don't vaporize me with your
legs what the hell
man well john
have you gotten off your high horse and
seen the damn show yet
yes i've been humbled i just finished it
last night and i
loved the heck out of it you guys were
right thank god he's actually
posted stuff on stardust about it check
my opinion on stardust
about damn time now we can do reactions
to it here
on youtube when the show comes out in
the meantime covering umbrella academy
season two over here with aaron
that reaction should be up within like
an hour to an hour and a half from this
being posted so hit that subscribe
button click the notification bell get
notified when that video is out
anywho let's see what's in store
and right now
are you [ __ ] with us i am not [ __ ]
with you
this is
[Music]
oh john carlo man he's on top
so she's still being held against her
will in some way is what it sounds like
okay
oh homelander is not happy about her
who the [ __ ] are you i'm just trying to
help
really how
[Music]
don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ] tits
oh my god oh
oh my god
[Music]
talking with him oh no
oh
god
you son of a bee
oh no no
you knew it was coming oh
oh that's a that's a late season moment
gonna have to be able to have to be able
to prove herself
starlight is damn all right let's talk
about that was great now with the way
how
uh season one ended now i could finally
talk to you about that
spend all video doing this but the way
how season one
ended raised all these questions about
what
becca is doing there with their son
right or within her homeland or son the
way the trailer's making it sound
especially with the way butch is talking
about it about getting his
wife back that there's something there
maybe something with vaught industries
of she is being
forced to be there still so being like
held in some kind of witness protection
of some kind yeah there's something
happening there because i couldn't tell
by the way that ended if it was like a
voluntary situation
if this is what she actually wanted or
if this is something
that would still give butch some hope in
order to get his wife back so it gives a
different motivation because last season
butch
being the main character was about
getting revenge yeah and this season
it's gonna be him
wanting to figure out a way to rescue
her and get her out of there now what's
gonna become of that kid though
he's gonna become homelander junior i'm
afraid because i feel like there could
be some interesting conflict to deal
with there
she's been raising that kid now we don't
know the dynamic there i don't know if
she like hates her son if it's like a
bright burn situation like i
i don't if she loves him but feverish
him you know like what is the dynamic
with becca
and whoever the boy is the boy yeah
the boy oh spin-off spin-off show oh
great i feel like that's a big
ingredient this character storm front
and uh i love i feel like they're
trailing my shirt a little too much
there oh crap oh homelander feels
threatened by her to some degree
and then oh no they're actually going to
be working together teaming up
on this yeah but as because the super t
you're more familiar with it than i am
because you just
finished it the super terrorist program
or whatever that was homelander created
that oh yeah
that's just him throwing his own little
hail mary to prove like
see i have good ideas important
but giving the world super villains to
keep the necessity
and even increase the industry of the
seven yeah right
just to push their agenda forward so it
seemed like the way at least the trailer
was communicating
that stormfront is under the impression
that
these are real villains that she's not
in on the know
about homeland or created them you know
yeah i mean
it seems like he would be still the only
one with that information given how the
first season ended and i
think that would create some interesting
conflict and maybe that'll be the
linchpin late in the season when she
truly finds out the nature of these
things
well i mean i feel like giancarlo
esposito might actually know
too yeah that's fair we don't know what
conversations they've had he's the one
above madeline right yeah he's the one
who's like you might even get my job
next season yeah
there's some impression i'm getting that
some of the people from the seven i
don't i don't think all of them but
there's
certain looks that are being given off
and then there's
some there's like a brief moment there
with a train and there's star girl and
huey there that i'm like why are they
interacting with each other is a train
having a bit of a change of heart
around the situation i feel like out of
any one of this the current seven other
than starlight of course she's on the
boys side but
it seems like she's you know undercover
now on this double agent
double agent yeah i feel like out of any
one of them it's gonna be a train more
than
it seems like the deep would because
they're going toe-to-toe with the deep
here
yeah and i mean just things get worse
and worse for him because yeah i don't
know that's
just the gag of that character but i
could imagine something
interesting maybe happening with a train
especially if
the where we left him in season one has
anything to do with that because they
could have easily left him to die
you know maybe something about that plus
the greater repercussions of him helping
a homeland or with this super terrorist
thing maybe they'll have a change
of heart or yeah or something you know
i'm also curious if
like if homelander already knows about
starlight
because it seems like that's what he's
doing at the end there like testing to
see
which side she's really on it's
homelander i feel like homelander would
know
he's already up front he was already
like super suspect of her in the first
season
yeah well then given his an age range
relationship again
it has to see what what he does
afterwards but you would think that
adrian would say something at the very
least
that's why i'm thinking a train is
probably
involved in some way with helping out
with the boys this time where he's
having some
you know duality in her complex of what
which side he should be
maybe he's a changed man yeah his
compound v attack you know he's gonna be
really cool this season
kim miko yeah i i get the impression
she's gonna shine in a lot cause she was
like when she got introduced she was
just very
dars character feral character yeah and
i feel like they're gonna have a lot
more
fun with her this time around well i
think she's gonna at least get to enjoy
being more of her own person because
it's
it's such a bummer that one scene in the
first season where like she you know
finally kind of makes herself up and
kind of you know
takes control for a moment and then they
just get attacked so yeah it seems cool
to see her in a more power position and
them you know even though they're on the
run and they're fugitives you know she
looks like she's gonna kick a lot of ass
and it seems like in terms of like
thematically and everything they're
still keeping a lot of that going like
with the monetization of superheroes you
got that
or whatever live stream commentary
moment they got going how they got out
of their social media
yeah i'm wondering what's going to
happen with storm for our homeland i
feel like stormfront
will be killed by him i could see it
happening i mean the thing is you know
he seems to have a thing for powerful
women so
he's going to want to be on top though
and i i think any time he has any kind
of threat i mean
he offed madeline you know yeah yeah
yeah so i imagine there could be some
sort of conflicted power struggle but i
would ultimately be afraid that yeah i
mean if he's not gonna kill her easily
he's gonna be gunning for her but yeah
or maybe she'll turn you know maybe
she'll start as this kind of hopeful
character who you maybe
see as an inroad to fixing the seven and
then that's taken away from us later on
and she goes full homelander you know
all right guys well
boys season two what do you guys think
of this trailer oh yeah
violent squirrel looks cool all that fun
stuff
yeah heroes satire but you know we're
nuanced in our discussions
you just do character studies i mean
that's just for the little boys
political parallels
are quite sophisticated anywho
i'm drinking that whale sequence does
look cool oh
more deep that's the one one way in
which i sympathize with that guy
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell check us out on
patreon where we cover a lot of
television shows
with uh full length reaction watch along
as many of those shows have reaction
highlights included last but not least
michael b i'm holding contact fluid omni
media who wears glasses and doesn't need
this
whoa i made it work power of improv
check out my autobiography
guys my autobiography is released
september 5th
2021. michael b wrote the foreword
to it he has a channel omni media he is
covering
so much television and so much of it is
superhero show
based i feel i think he just wrapped up
doom patrol
i love this man's opinions i love his
editing style as well
he really deserves all the support in
the world if you guys like this channel
he made it to this part of the video
i sincerely mean it please go over to
his channel
there's a link in the description box
for him you will not regret it and
i'm hoping to have some more zoom
collabs with the guy in the future my i
wanted to finish up doing patrol in time
but editing for umbrella academy is
taking up way too much time
michael b love you buddy hope to see you
thrive some more in the future we'll
talk soon
[Music]
you